want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you have michael jordan
level talent at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
why bitcoin is a great investment
enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one own digital energy with michael
saylor once you realize that bitcoin is
digital property or digital money or
digital energy
all of these things
then it becomes clear that everything
else you could possibly own is inferior
to that
right
you would really never want to own
anything other than
pure digital energy
right like why do you want to own a
building right
the only reason you want to own a
building is
you're going to freeze to death
if you didn't have something to come in
from the cold too right like you would
own a building to live in because
otherwise you're going to freeze to
death okay that's a good reason but with
all your discretionary energy beyond
that if you chose to own a 50-story
skyscraper in manhattan
is that as good as digital no because
the mayor of manhattan can seize your
building by eminent domain
if you're thinking you're going to rent
the building out
you know the politician can tell you
that you're not allowed to evict any of
your tenants even they don't pay you
right so the property in the physical
realm can be impaired by any political
jurisdiction
anyone anyone with jurisdiction over the
property and that means
that means the neighborhood
review board right the neighborhood
building committee can tell you you
can't put an awning in front of your
building the mayor the governor
every every regulator osha
you know
environmental review boards the congress
the senate the white house
everybody in in that physical
domain can impair the value of your
property
so
not only that
it's going to be impaired the second is
it's going to be taxed
right because when they decide to tax
your building you can't move your
building
and the third is the building is not
appealing to anybody else in the
universe like if i'm a billionaire in
beijing why would i want a skyscraper in
manhattan if it's if it's illegal for me
to travel to manhattan why would i want
to pay for that thing
so if you have a billion dollars of
property in manhattan it's not it's not
fungible and it's not desirable
everywhere else on earth
what i want is something that is
universally desirable through all space
time
how desirable will your building be in
500 years
right
buildings
not right and so there's another
interesting dynamic here with physical
property there's a maintenance cost
the cost of maintenance is the
theoretical investment every year you
have to make in order to preserve the
property value
you know if you ever own a boat
you know what that is stop investing in
the boat the boat sinks if you own a
building
like what's the useful life of a
building 40 years 80 years 100 years
show me a building in manhattan that's
still good 200 years later
still desirable
so
property
property in the physical domain
doesn't hold its value through time
and it doesn't hold its value through
space
and it's not fungible
right the rockefeller center
is not the same thing
as a thousand acres in kansas
they're different things the rockefeller
center is not even the same thing as
another big building in manhattan
[Music]
whereas a bitcoin is the same as a
bitcoin
and we're back to your issue like where
do you get rid of volatility one bitcoin
equals one bitcoin uh and it means the
same thing
whether or not what is one bitcoin 121
millionth of all the energy in the
network
and
what is it going to be in a thousand
years
121 millionth of all the energy in the
network
okay
who's that interesting too
everybody
that joins the network
who can join the network
it's open for permissionless anybody
on earth can join the network
okay so is that everybody well not
everybody because some people haven't
joined the network
but
it is more inclusive than any other
thing any other property network
a building in manhattan is interesting
to people that do business in manhattan
land in the us is interesting to people
that can traverse or do business in the
us
a picasso
is interesting property to people who
appreciate picassos
right i mean presumably
a lot of people do but not everyone does
right so if you look at all the other
things you can own gold gold has value
to people that value gold
okay art
metals commodities
bullets bullets have value to people
that want to fire the bullets but if the
bullet doesn't actually fit in your gun
then it's pretty much useless to you
it's like a rock
very you know there's a certain bullet
you want certain bullet you don't want
so
why bitcoin
well bitcoin is the most universally
desirable
property
in space and time
it's the property with the lowest
maintenance cost
you can put a billion dollars of bitcoin
in coal storage and you don't have to
pay two percent a year to maintain it or
five percent a year or ten percent a
year
the maintenance cost on a boat is ten
percent a year the maintenance cost on a
building is three percent a year
the maintenance cost on fill in the
blank
you know
pay to store your gold pay to store your
artwork pay to store your
whatever it is there's a cost
you want a company well there's a cost
to own a company you actually get
diluted by the share by the ceo or the
executive team and issue stock options
you know if the company didn't have any
employees
right and didn't have any cost then
maybe there wouldn't be as much
maintenance but you know what do you
call a company that has no employees and
no maintenance costs well
bitcoin like
it becomes something else
so i think that when you embrace bitcoin
as your property strategy
you can get away from the maintenance
cost
the likelihood is going to be impaired
decreases exponentially
uh the law it's a lot harder to seize a
billion dollars of bitcoin than it is to
seize a billion dollars of land or
billion of art or a billion of gold or a
billion of a building or a building of
stock
exponentially harder rule number two
look at the math with greg foss let's
say that uh
uh
we end up with a couple of million
dollars per bitcoin um being the uh kind
of end state if you will right so yeah
much much more valuable than it is today
do we get institutions to adopt then you
know kind of developing nations and then
there's a default and there's an
inflection point like how do you think
we sequentially get there what does that
like order of operations almost look
like so great question so firstly i'll
detail how or not detail it'll be a
quick explanation of how i get to my two
thousand dollars at two million dollars
or greater per coin very simply today
total global financial assets in the
world today
are over u.s
900 trillion dollars now that includes
all equities all debt all currency all
fine art all gold
900 trillion us dollars all real estate
sorry i forgot to mention real estate
globally
i think that bitcoin has a chance of
becoming the global reserve asset of the
world why because i think
oil and natural gas will shortly and
when i say shortly within the next 10
years
become priced in bitcoin why is that
well i'm an engineer
the rule of conservation of energy
you've certainly heard michael saylor
say that oil and natural gas if you're
russia do you actually want to sell your
valuable natural resources for this
thing called the us dollar which is a
programmed 2d base
fiat currency or do you want to hold us
treasuries which is a fiat contract
that's also programmed to debase or
would you like to sell your
natural resource energy for
bitcoin which is digital energy i think
yes i think over time there will be
enough people or nations that want to
price bitcoin or energy and bitcoin when
that happens that becomes the reserve
asset of the world so what percentage of
the reserve asset does it make sense
that 900 trillion dollars could capture
would it be five percent i think that's
pretty low but let's assume it's five
percent of 900 trillion u.s dollars five
percent of 900 trillion is 45 trillion
dollars 45 trillion
divided by 21 million bitcoin
that's over two million dollars of
bitcoin okay it's that simple now
could it go higher than two million abso
freaking lutely okay but let's just use
two million dollars per bitcoin as a
base case scenario how does it get there
it gets there something like you know
you have what happens in el salvador a
little bit and then it gets there
because michael saylor the genius of
wall street figures that every single
corporation should actually issue debt
in order to
capture a certainty of debate
contract
in trade for
this thing called
bitcoin at the end of the day you'll get
institutions you'll have a combination
of countries institutions
um hedge funds
all of this will add to a higher price
we've seen it happen before the the the
reality though pump is when energy is
priced in bitcoin that will remove the
petrol dollar focus it will become the
de facto reserve asset of the world and
you will see a gap up in price that will
blow your socks off in my opinion does
it have to happen no but run some
probability analysis on what
a two million dollar and that's in
today's dollars what a two million
dollar price of bitcoin on an expected
value basis needs to be
versus bitcoin potentially going to zero
which i also don't think is like even
a price that it'll ever return to but
assume that you have only two outcomes a
binary outcome
one is a price of bitcoin of zero
and the other one is a price of bitcoin
of two million dollars a coin
i'll ask you this question would you
give me a ten percent chance that
bitcoin can go to two million dollars a
coin if i gave you the 90 chance it goes
to zero
and most people would say yeah
you know that sounds about fair and the
reality is well on an expected value
basis for that one calculation 90 times
zero is zero and ten percent times two
million bucks a coin is 200 000 a coin
hey there's another example of why you
should be buying bitcoin today with your
eyes closed don't overthink this okay
it's a game of probabilities it always
is a game of probabilities no one is
ever a hundred percent certain about
anything in investing except this
i am a hundred percent certain that
fiats will continue to debase because
they cannot possibly stop printing money
due to the debt debt spiral
that all fiat countries are in today it
is a hundred percent certain
mathematically that fiat currencies will
continue to debase and will continue to
debase on it on an accelerated basis
pure math rule number three view it as
money with raul paul what's so
interesting about ethereum it's
everything
you know i actually bought my first nft
today
um and look everything's priced in
congrats was it a cryptocurrency you got
to tell us more about that right yeah
it's nothing it's nothing exciting i
just thought i'd have to do it
we'll come on to that when we talk about
nfts in a bit but
it was priced at
0.758
so ether's money and i'd seen that
because we can commission for real
vision up uh kind of headquarters in uh
crypto voxels which we're just you know
we're going to release soon just for the
fun of it
and the architects we paid beneath and
the land we paid an eighth
so it's like okay well eath is clearly
money
beneath his technology
we know that too
um eth is also a platform of which
people are building a lot of different
applications
so whether we talk about community
tokens nfts
defy a whole bunch of stuff
um dows they're all going to be on east
now will eath be
the only chain no
clearly people use solana for stuff
people use and there'll be a multi-chain
world of which there'll be a few giants
and a long tale of stuff and that's
pretty normal
um but heath has got really interesting
because of this
and then you know i came out with a
piecing global macro investor last month
called the greatest trade
and you know here's my macro head-on
again is okay we've got this adoption
that is kind of exponential right it's
growing at least twice
twice the rate of
of bitcoin
and it's by far dwarfing the rest of the
space
then
the eip 1559 comes along
and that reduces the supply
so that's clearly bullish for the price
and then you look at the on-chain
analytics
and everyone is bloody staking it
because now it's a pretty clear run
between now and e 2.0 so why would you
not if you're a long-term holder
so everybody's taking it so that's taken
a ton of stuff off the exchange there's
tons that have gone into just holding
tons that are locked up in d5 tons that
are locked up in nfts
and you're left with i don't know as of
today 11 of the entire supply of
ethereum available and it's going down
every day
and
the demand is going exponential the only
outcome is an exponential rise in price
there's no other outcome rule number
four forget inflation with robert
breedlove bitcoin
is the first permanent implementation of
this principle we've been refining
throughout human history of inviolable
property
it actually cannot be violated in any
way
no one can produce more than 21 million
bitcoin so it's
and i've argued this in some of my
writing that although it's an invention
we've actually discovered something with
bitcoin we've discovered
absolute scarcity for money so if we're
back to those five properties of money
in terms of scarcity bitcoin is absolute
it's not relative right it doesn't
change we know with
you know
nothing's um
people argue with me about this it's not
absolute everything's probabilistic true
uh bitcoin has proven itself over 13
years of flawless operation that it does
two things
essentially perfectly
which are turn out a block on
one block of transactions on average
every 10 minutes and adhere to a supply
cap of 21 million
so it's the first fixed supply money
there has ever been
and i don't think you can recreate that
because by definition
money is a centripetal network effect so
it we tend towards one so for the same
reasons we had one analog gold we're
likely only to have one digital gold
um
this
so your property rights cannot be
violated by inflation because no one can
change the supply cap if you hold a
thousand bitcoin
you hold 1 000 of a possible 21 million
forever right you have a guaranteed
fraction of the total money supply
you cannot get that level of assurance
with any other asset in the world
full stop doesn't exist even with gold
you can hold all the physical gold you
want
you're still not immune to
uh some technological breakthrough we
figured out figured out how to produce
gold in the lab very cheaply we mine an
asteroid we're mine the ocean floor we
find a new south american bonanza
whatever you're not immune to any of
that but with bitcoin
and again it's a bit of a bet because
it's only 13 years in but it's done
these things perfectly so far
if it continues to do what it's been
doing for 13 years you have a guaranteed
fraction of total money supply so you
have an inviolable property right
further
[Music]
this is again property is the
relationship right we've historically
always needed an enforcer
so you need the police force you need
the military to make sure no one comes
into your house and violates your
relationship with your house
we needed
if maybe not necessarily a monopoly on
violence but you needed a protection
producing enterprise which historically
is the role of government to enshrine
your property rights
the problem of course is that they
willed the power to violate your
property rights as well which
historically has been very tempting for
governments and bureaucrats they
typically give into it and governments
get overthrown over time that's been the
cycle we're locked into
bitcoin's the first property
right independent
of the monopoly on violence
or independent of
uh physical protection production
it's an informational property right
it's just an alphanumeric string you can
store it in any information bearing
medium put in your mind put on your
computer put it in a song do whatever
you want with it
and there's no the enforcement is done
by the mining network so the algorithm
and the
free market competition that's going
into bitcoin mining is effectively
displacing
the protection that government was
historically necessary to provide in
bitcoin itself
so
it's this radical new you know some
people call it a metaphysical property
right and that it's just an information
bearer asset
so gold was really good as a bear asset
in that
you know assets equal liabilities plus
equity the accounting equation
gold was pure equity if i hold gold it's
no one else's liability that's really
important right i have no counterparty
risk if i hold physical gold
if i hold dollars that's not true right
i have this liability to the federal
reserve to the bank whoever whatever
counterparties are
involved bitcoins the same as physical
gold but it's non-physical right it's
informational
so it opens up this entire new
sphere of possibilities and how you
custody it you can custody bitcoin in
these multi-signature schemas that are
all but immune to theft you can chop the
key into a bunch of pieces and
distribute it geographically you have
these military-grade protocols wrapped
around it
and it gives you
an absolute it
it is the highest
implementation
of human self-ownership we've ever had
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five look for minimal
risk with kathy wood we've been evolving
our point of view on ether when we when
we started our analysis we were pretty
much
and this was with chris uh bitcoin was
uh uh what we needed to understand first
uh but we were keeping our eye on all of
the other assets and and we stuck pretty
closely to the
thesis the fat protocol thesis that
chris's partner joel monegro came up
with at
union square ventures
which says that
the value accrual will take place more
at the currency level and we believe
there would be only a few currencies uh
in the world much like uh there are
today we thought we thought bitcoin
would be the reserve currency and we
were looking for the other currencies
and and ether was showing uh uh where
was showing up as uh a very strong
second
um and and i have been surprised at how
uh how
how ether
and the ethereum network is mushrooming
with stable coins nfts uh
decentralized finance it's clearly
satisfying a huge unmet need
one of those needs is yield out there
and and we see that in the fixed income
markets
the the ridiculous uh
rallies that have taken place taking
junk bond yields down to
you know just a couple of hundred basis
points above treasuries that's kind of
nuts
uh uh so this this
this hunger for yield is being satisfied
by a much more efficient uh financial
ecosystem and i think many more people
are more open-minded to it
as well
um
let's see one of the things that has
struck me from the beginning and when
chris started
at arc which was very close to the
beginning of the firm
i remember saying very early on follow
the developers follow the developers
well
using
that metric
ethereum is off the charts you know
uh whereas bitcoin is steady as she goes
still increasing uh steady as she goes
but clearly ethereum
decentralized finance nfts
have hit a responsive cord i think
bringing the creator community into this
ecosystem uh is you know helping it go a
little bit
viral more quickly than we would have
expected i absolutely can see that
especially since
monetary policies around the world have
pretty much become unhinged and
you know talk about trust
i think there's more trust in this
ecosystem
you know in in the way you've defined it
risk minimized uh than there might be in
the traditional world rule number six do
your research with brock pierce how was
an investor i think is the bigger
question
do you know which cryptos to trust
yeah so i i think you can watch any
interview
any speech
i've ever made and i don't think i've
ever encouraged anyone to buy more than
a hundred dollars worth of bitcoin
because i don't want to give people
financial advice i want to give people
the
encouragement
to
participate to get involved so that they
can make informed decisions for
themselves you know uh the the world is
changing and the future is going to
happen to you or with you and i
encourage everyone to get involved
but it starts with the process of
learning you know it's hard for anyone
to take advantage of you if you're
making decisions for yourself it's very
easy to be taken advantage of when
people say go do this and you follow
blindly uh and so in the future you're
gonna need some training and that's how
to secure and protect your things and
all that stuff but um the thing that i
do when looking at projects
um you know what what determines
long-term success remember this is open
source technology
so you can copy anything
first mover advantage being first gives
you a window of opportunity but it won't
sustain what you're building long-term
the long-term value of these projects
are what what problem are you trying to
solve right there's a lot of solutions
looking for a problem uh you want to
make sure that there's
there's a fundamental premise to what is
this attempting to solve for and and why
do you think it's going to work um the
community is is probably the most
important thing you know the community
that's behind it you know do you have uh
enough critical mass of people
supporting it talking about it you know
uh uh believing in it having faith in it
um and then ultimately the leadership as
well you know who are the the key
individuals um behind the project and go
watch their videos and do they give you
do they give you comfort you know when
that when this person talks but does it
inspire confidence uh
do your you know red flags go off uh and
and you know do your research is the
best advice and and trust your judgment
rule number seven use it as a store of
value with mark cuban when bitcoin first
started really becoming popular and the
early did this put aside 2009 10 11 12
right um you know i was very familiar
with the very familiar with blockchain
but the original
presentation or narrative if you will
was that it was a currency right that it
was going to be used as a currency by
normal people in normal circumstances
and i i just never saw that happening to
this day i don't see it as being a
replacement currency for the us dollar
or for any sovereign nation for that
matter is it a better way to transfer
money yeah of course right is that are
there significant benefits to um to
bitcoin yeah of course but it's really
evolved to being a store of value for
the longest time store value was not the
you know was not the key to bitcoin
right there was going to be lightning
and that was going to allow all these
transactions to take place and yada yada
and so that to me never got me excited
because i i still don't think that'll
happen
but i've always thought it could be a
store of value i've always compared it
to gold and you know it's what people
will pay for but what really changed is
over the last year
um as i started getting more into smart
contracts in particular and really
understanding more about their
capability and seeing the enhancements
that had been made that was the first
thing that got me excited what made me
really blow up on it and really get
fired up about it is when i went to
mintable.app and minted my first nft
and it wasn't so much just minting the
process but when i saw the royalties
right
that was the game changer
because the challenge for all
intellectual property whether it's art
whether it's music whether it's
photography whether it's a
textbook whether it's anything is the
rule of first sale right once you sell
it everybody else has got the right to
sell it and you don't get a nickel from
it
and this changes all of that
and the implications there and the
applications are enormous so that was
the first thing that got me started with
nfts then i started digging in more on
the d5 stuff because you can't miss you
know from this summer right i mean deep
i was everywhere and all anybody talked
about it seemed like and so i started
digging in and there's a lot of hype you
know a lot of
bs going around and a lot of you know
the yield farming thing and apy and
token binging and all this kind of stuff
but what got me excited is really
understanding that
d5 turned bitcoin or ethereum or even
several other tokens into personal
banking right and friction free personal
banking you know with with
the money i have in some of my bank
accounts right i still got to go to a
banker and i still have to fill out
paperwork and it's still a multi-day
process and that's ridiculous right even
you know even though i'm over
collateralized and and i have a big nvl
in my personal accounts right and so
you know then i started looking at it
and realized that okay put aside the
over collateralization that's not really
a limiting factor um
but i can borrow or anybody can borrow
regardless of size in seconds
and it's this decentralization really
working to turn crypto into a personal
banking platform and that to me is the
most exciting um aspect of d5 and then
you start applying that to corporations
and then you start extending
nfts and smart contracts in particular
and so you can mint anything anything
that's digital becomes a digital
tokenizable
asset that can be resold
all those things together and it really
is something to get excited about
because not only can it change how
people deal with their own personal
assets and their own you know borrowing
and lending money but also for companies
it can really allow them to monetize
things they've never been able to
monetize before rule number eight it's
portable with robert kiyosaki here's
stocks
the government will will make sure it
doesn't crash
gold will not crash
but krepto could
you know why because the fed doesn't
want it
because the reason i like crypto reason
i buy bitcoin and ethereum and all that
stuff is i don't like the fed when i
talk to most of the young guys they
don't like the fat either
[Music]
but the problem is and this is why
you've got to be smarter
is that the fed wants to take this out
the european central bank these ecb
wants to take it out the bank of japan
wants to take it out the bank of china
wants to take it out
so that's why you crypto guys you've got
to be smarter today i love bitcoin
because it's portable
no storage problems it's important
currency
so that's why i'm very bullish i'm very
optimistic about bitcoin because it's
going to be chaos for the next 10 years
and bitcoin will go up and down up and
down up and down up and down if here i
go up and down block channel go up and
down rule number nine protect your
assets with chamath pali hapatia when i
look at bitcoin it is one of the most
interesting things happening in that
financial services pillar that i've ever
seen and the reason i like it so much
are two things one is it is for the
first time you know the cheapest and
most frictionless payment rails we've
ever seen
and so forget bitcoin as an underlying
currency you don't have to care about
whether it replaces fiat dollars or not
what you have to care about is that
instead of paying two and a half percent
or one and a half percent i can
basically pay virtually nothing to clear
and basically process transactions and
get money from one account to another
account right from one address to
another address which is effectively
what today's payment rails
do for people
so what that allows you to do is much
more profitably have businesses that can
basically accept and take payments for
anything for any kind of good and
service and so as a result more services
will exist and as a result more
interesting creative uses of those
payment rails will happen that's the
most primary thing
but then the secondary thing which is
again going back to
these trends which i think is more
societal in nature is that you have an
increasing level of mistrust around the
monetary and fiscal policy for many
governments including the united states
and so when you think about things that
could span anywhere from at the simple
end devaluation to all the way at the
other end asset seizures by you know
federal institutions
and if you don't think those are
happening those are happening today you
know we're going to go through a
devaluation in brazil we're probably
going through a devaluation in india
these are two of the most important
economies in the world
poland just seized half of the you know
sort of private pension assets poland eu
country
right so that they could basically lower
their debt to gdp ratio so that they
could borrow more money and so if you're
sitting in any of these countries
right and you're thinking to yourself
wow i've worked hard
i've played by the rules i've saved
money i'm trying to do very simple
things with it buy a house have a
vacation pay for a car pay for my kids
to go to school pass that on pay for my
daughter's wedding and now you have to
deal with these you know people who
frankly mismanaged didn't know what they
were doing were put in a position of
power simply because they were able to
check a box and have a degree and
convince somebody else to check the box
and had a degree that they were just as
smart as them
all this [ __ ] flows downhill and then
you pay the price what would you do and
i look at bitcoin and i say my god like
you can protect your assets
so at a very very basic level if there's
any fiscal or monetary instability in a
country or you don't believe or trust
what's happening you should absolutely
have a percent of your assets there this
is no different when the nazis were
killing jews left right and center they
were able to basically transfer wealth
into things like diamonds into and they
were able to at least protect themselves
somewhat but even then they were
severely taken advantage of right
but now you can take that to a much more
structural you know uniform scale
applied to everybody right so if you're
a venezuela and you've been playing by
the rules and now you don't like what's
happening there you can get your money
or your assets into bitcoin and shield
it from a government you fundamentally
don't trust
i mean how is that a bad idea that's
like this is genius
right i mean
we're sitting around here right now most
of our assets in u.s dollars hoping to
god that someone between larry summers
or janet yellen knows what the hell
they're doing
just say i mean just so you guys know
we've been printing money out the yin
yang for about eight or nine years and
now we're hoping that once the printing
press stops that one of those two people
can figure it out
and all i'm saying is and i know larry
very well and i think larry's is a
genius and i think larry would do a
fantastic job even larry can only
control it so much and so i frankly have
worked too hard for what i've earned and
i just want to protect it and i want to
be able to do whatever i want with it i
don't want to be told what others think
i just don't give a [ __ ] what others
think and so that's why i think bitcoin
is so amazing so
as a business service it's genius and
then secondarily sort of like as an
instrument of protecting
assets and asset value
i think that will start as a developing
world phenomenon
and i think it'll spill over to the
developed world and so you're talking
about a 20-year arc but this thing is
going to rip it's just going to continue
to go up and to the right and rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is understand the
blockchain with gary vaynerchuk gary
bitcoin or ethereum
ethereum why because it's more of a
platform than the singular brand it's
blockchain and it's ethereum then it's
bitcoin so i don't think people
understand right it's like it's like
wordpress and netscape navigator or
yahoo.com bitcoin
could win and could become a brand like
a nike and could be amazing and all that
but ethereum is the infrastructure above
which you build on top of
blockchain bless you blockchain
is the most gangster going on and i'll
explain why when you talk if you truly
understand the chess moves of
decentralizing everything well then the
whole damn world's on call
government's included
i want to talk about the thesis around
bitcoin will stay specific to that
because i know would you do you call
yourself a bitcoin maxi no so i think
there's um a separation between there's
monetary component of this and then
there's like a technology or like a
corporate component of it the monetary
part you have to be a maximalist right
you're a fiat maximalist if you're a us
citizen you get paid in dollars you save
in dollars you invest in dollar
denominated assets you pay your taxes in
dollars so you're a fiat u.s dollar
maximalist
when it comes to monetary assets
everyone in the world is a maximalist
because that is what you denominate your
wealth in right very very rarely does
somebody say hey 50 is in this currency
50 is in this currency and so from a
monetary standpoint definitely a bitcoin
maximalist because i think bitcoin is
the only one that has an opportunity to
actually um kind of
ascend to global reserve status and end
up being the superior uh monetary form
but when it looks at the technology i
think that there's going to be massive
competition on that so if you look at
the technology side of it where you're
not talking about monetary asset you're
actually talking about a technology
asset
it would be like saying you're an ios
maximalist or you're uh you know i don't
know python maximal it's very depending
on the language or the platform or
whatever so i think that you've got to
be able to separate out and say you know
bitcoin is competing with uh fiat
currencies for store value medium of
exchange etc and really fast fiat just
means it's government-backed just
government-backed and and basically they
control it so the the key definitions
here are a fiat currency versus let's
call it sound money all sound money is
is basically something outside of the
system and something that people can't
create more of so gold is a analog
version of sound bites a physical form
of sound money created by stars
exploding just i mean when i heard that
i was like god yeah that really is an
interesting way to think about why it's
scarce yeah and bitcoin is a digital
form of sound money and so you can
compare the sound money to the fiat
money um and you know it becomes pretty
clear pretty quickly to people it's like
okay one is uh completely abundant and
can be created at will 38 has been
created in the last 18 months versus one
that nobody can create more of well i
don't need to know much else other than
that to know which one's gonna end up
being more valuable and so if we look
over the last 12 years or so bitcoin's
purchasing power and all purchasing
power means is how much does it cost to
buy you know a good um the purchasing
power has appreciated it's increased so
all of the expenses around you all the
the physical items that you buy have
gotten cheaper and cheaper so it used to
cost me one bitcoin to buy a loaf of
bread now it might cost me 0.0001
bitcoin to buy a bread okay that's
pretty interesting the dollar is the
opposite right it cost me more dollars
to buy the bread so everything's getting
more expensive around me
[Music]
if you want to know what other
successful entrepreneurs think of
bitcoin check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i know i could lose this is vegas
and bitcoin fits that category for me
bitcoin is like a zodiac
next to the us dollars titanic there's a
city out here where the whole city is
cryptocurrency